[Musik]
bismark erst ist die blm unique lieber
herunter liebe gäste
vielen dank für die einladung und vielen
dank dass ich heute hier zu ihnen
sprechen darf ich muss mich gleich vorab
ein bisschen entschuldigen ist es mal
wieder so ein tolles semester dass ich
in zwei hinsichten ein bisschen also
nicht ganz so das machen kann wie ich
mir das in einer idealen welt gewünscht
hätte das eine ist ich werde den vortrag
doch ablesen müssen weil ich ihnen noch
nicht gut also weil ich das noch nicht
gut genug präpariert aber um es ohne zu
können und das andere ist es ist doch
wie das manchmal ist wenn man nicht so
viel zeit hat es nochmal durch zu denken
oder noch mal durchzumachen das ist eben
das da arbeite ich im moment dran an
diesem thema ist an vielen stellen
sicherlich sehr dicht und sehr also zu
sehr für leute geschrieben die sich auch
sehr auskennen ich habe aber nichts
dagegen wenn sie mich unterbrechen wenn
sie den eindruck haben dass ist jetzt
eine stelle die ich rein von den
begriffen schon nicht verstehe oder wo
das irgendwie in dem punkt was ist was
ich gern erläutert habe dann dürfen sie
mich obwohl ich hier ja irgendwie jetzt
vorlesen werden dürfen sie mich gerne
unterbrechen und an der stelle kurz
nachfragen also die diskussion soll
danach geführt werden aber solche
nachfragen sind mir durchaus willkommen
also ich möchte zu ihnen sprechen über
kants methode in der philosophie wenn
man nach khans philosophischer methode
fragt so kann man damit ganz
verschiedenes meinen
bekanntlich hat kann selbst eine
synthetische von einer analytischen
methode unterschieden und er hat
beispielsweise seine schrift die kritik
der reinen vernunft als eine
transzendentale philosophie also eine
grundlegende abhandlung zu den
bedingungen von erkenntnis von denen
dann inhaltlichen ausführungen einer
metaphysik der metaphysik der natur und
der metaphysik
sitten abgegrenzt all das könnte man im
blick haben wenn man über kahns methode
spricht daneben kann man fragen ob
bekannt alle philosophischen setzte
setzte a priori sind oder ob sie
synthetische oder gar analytische setzte
apriori sind ich kann heute diese fragen
natürlich nicht alle behandeln
sie führen unweigerlich auf fast alle
zentralen themen der philosophie und
übersteigen daher jedes format für einen
abendvortrag in meinem vortrag verdi
stattdessen eine these zug ans methode
entwickeln
diese allgemein ist und lautet das
bekannt philosophieren
eine reflektion auf die eigenen
fähigkeiten und denkt handlungen ist bei
der wii funktionen und grenzen von
begriffen einsehen
das soll nicht heißen dass sind ganz
philosophie nicht bisweilen auch beweise
geführt werden oder um es mit kann zu
sagen begriffe als gültig erwiesen oder
grundsätze als gesetze der erfahrung
aufgestellt werden
letzteres sind philosophische
erkenntnisse im strikten sinne
daneben ist philosophie aber in weiten
teilen analyse unserer denkt handlungen
dieser analyse will keine erkenntnis im
engeren sinne sein so meine thesen eine
solche these lässt sich so denke ich nur
sinnvoll an einem beispiel aufzeigen und
es muss natürlich am besten ein beispiel
sein bei dem es kann nicht um den
nachweis der gültigkeit von etwas geht
daher werde ich mich im zentrum dieses
vortrags mit einem teil aus ganz
dialektik beschäftigen nämlich ganz
analyse der an termin der vernunft oder
genauer mit der dritten antinori der
vernunft im folgenden werde ich zunächst
in die thematik einführen und dann werde
ich diese interpretation der dritten
antinori vorstellen und dann möchte ich
einige konsequenzen
aus dieser interpretation für die frage
nach ganz methode in der philosophie
ziehen diese dreiteilung eines vortrags
finden sie auch auf dem handy
wenn philosophie eine kritik der reinen
vernunft sein kann also vernunft als
subjekt und objekt der kritik wie der
titel von kants hauptwerk kritik der
reinen vernunft an zu zeigen scheint
dann ist klar dass es sich um eine
priorisierung handeln soll
in der die vernunft irgendwie mit sich
selbst beschäftigt ist vernunft wird von
kant verstanden als das vermögen das
unsere denkt tätigkeit und daher auch
das verstandes vermögen umfasst
sie wird aber auch verstanden als ein
dem verstand entgegengesetztes vermögen
diese zwei bedeutung von vernunft kommen
deshalb zustande weil es sich in der
selbstkritik der vernunft ergibt dass
nur die tätigkeit des verstandes zu
erlangen von objektiver erkenntnis
geeignet ist während dieser tätigkeit
andere intellektuelle tätigkeiten als
nicht zu objektiven erkenntnis führend
gegenübergestellt werden müssen
diese verbleibenden werden dann abermals
unter dem titel vernunft zusammengefasst
der gegenüberstellung von verstand und
vernunft entspricht die
gegenüberstellung von analytik und
dialektik in der kritik der reinen
vernunft obwohl die ganze kritik eine
kritik der vernunft ist die rede von
einer vernunft die sich selbst
kritisiert mutet komisch an
ich denke man kann diese rede von der
sich mit sich beschäftigen denn vernunft
so verstehen wie ich zu anfangs gesagt
habe es ist eine reflektion des menschen
auf die eigenen fähigkeiten und denkt
handlungen bei der wir funktionen und
grenzen von begriffen einsehen
es findet hier also denke ich keine
reine begriffs analyse statt das player
auch eine möglichkeit für die sophie als
reine begriffs analyse zu sehen
es werden vielmehr fähigkeiten
analysiert also etwa die zu raum
zeitlicher wahrnehmung die fähigkeit zu
urteilen oder auch die fähigkeit ideen
zu bilden mit kants these dass die
grenzen unserer möglichen erkenntnis
durch die bezogenheit der begriff
für auf mögliche sinnliche gegenstände
festgelegt sind ist auch nicht gemeint
dass wir diese grenzen haben weil wir
nur in diesem bereich gehaltvolle
begriffe haben
das ist ja bei kann nicht so dass wir
nur begriffe haben die sich auf
sämtliche gegenstände beziehen
natürlich können wir auch begriffe von
etwas haben was kein sinnlichen
gegenstand darstellt und wer kann sind
diese begriffe und das unterscheidet ihn
von vielen moderneren philosophen für
kann sind diese begriffe nicht ohne
bedeutung
dennoch erfüllen sie nicht die
erkenntnis bedingungen und daher können
wir anhand ihrer nicht strikt erkennen
aber wie kommen wir dann zu diesen
begriffen warum haben wir sie und was
müssen wir bei ihnen beachten
diese fragen will kant in seiner
philosophie klären also unter anderem er
tut dies in seiner analyse unserer denkt
tätigkeit in der dialektik also in dem
teil der kritik der reinen vernunft er
direkte geist mit der theorie von ideen
werde ich mich im folgenden beschäftigen
und zeigen wie kann sich die bildung von
ideen zumindest in einem fall nämlich in
dem fall der dritten anonyme gedacht hat
es soll hierbei deutlich werden wie kant
zu seinen annahmen über die ideen kommt
dass sich aus diesen überlegungen auch
weitere folgerungen für kans methode
ziehen lassen werde ich im dritten teil
meines vortrags 2 damit komme ich also
zu dem längeren zweiten teil meines
vortrags die dritte antinori im
folgenden werde ich die dritte antenne
me aus der kritik der reinen vernunft
interpretieren
der fokus der interpretation und den
fokus der interpretation bildet dabei
die frage wie wir zu ideen kommen und
was diese sind allgemein sind für kant
ideen begriffe von einer ganzheit alit
sind also besondere begriff sie zeichnen
sich dadurch aus dass sie keinen oder
zumindest nur einen sehr indirekten
erfahrungs bezug haben und daher nach
kant auch nicht zu erkenntnissen
transzendentale ideen sind eine
besondere art von ideen
bei ihnen wird auch begriffe
des verstandes bezug genommen wenn wir
über die antinori in reden reden wir
über die kosmologischen ideen also es
wieder eine besondere art der
transzendentalen ideen
daneben gibt es für kant noch die
psychologische idee der seele und die
theologische idee gottes als
transzendentale ideen
ich denke dass man bei einer
interpretation der transzendentalen
ideen insgesamt beachten muss das für
diese verschiedene trans verschiedenen
transzendentalen ideen keineswegs
dasselbe gilt sie werden nicht auf
dieselbe weise gebildet und haben auch
nicht dieselben eigenschaften
das werde ich heute hier nicht
entwickeln es ist aber für uns insofern
wichtig als dass daraus folgt dass das
was mit blick auf die kosmologischen
ideen gesagt wird nicht für die anderen
transzendentalen ideen gelten muss wie
sich zeigen sollte geht nämlich bei den
kosmologischen ideen was kann manchmal
ganz pauschal über transzendentale ideen
sagt nämlich dass sie gebildet werden
indem man sich auf verstandes begriffe
auf die kategorien bezieht dazu woher
wir die kosmologischen ideen haben sagt
kant die vernunft ab zeuge keine
begriffe sondern mache die verstandes
begriffe von den unvermeidlichen
einschränkungen einer möglichen
erfahrung frei er fährt fort
zitat dieses geschieht dadurch dass zu
einem gegebenen bedingten absolute
totalität fordert und dadurch die
kategorie zur transzendentalen idee
gemacht wird die vernunft tut dies so
kant um der empirischen synthesis
vollständigkeit zu geben
in diesem sinn sagt kant auch dass die
trans transzendentalen ideen eigentlich
nicht seien als zitat bis zum
unbedingten erweiterte kategorien
man kann daher wohl sogar von einer idee
der kausalität im unterschied zur
kategorie der kausalität reden
jedenfalls muss es eine idee geben die
der kategorie der kausalität entspricht
im folgenden möchte ich erläutern was
kann mit diesen äußern
die ich hier paraphrasiert oder zitiert
habe gemeint hat was sind kosmologische
ideen und wie kommen wir zu ihnen
ich werde mich hier auf die dritte angie
nomi konzentrieren
diese wort wird oft antinori der
freiheit genannt es scheint mir aber
wichtig von anfang an klar zu machen
dass die dritte anime ihren ausgang
nicht wie man vielleicht durch spätere
debatten über kompatibel ismus annehmen
könnte bei den beiden für uns aus
verschiedenen gründen wichtigen
behaupten nicht dass wir auf der a3 sind
und dass wir auf der anderen seite
determiniert sind also zwei aussagen die
sich zu widersprechen scheinen sie nimmt
ihren ausgang vielmehr bei der frage
nach dem richtigen verständnis von
qualität stehen sich hier nicht freiheit
und determinismus als ausgangsfrage
gegenüber sondern es geht um das
richtige verständnis von kausalität
behauptet das ist für kosmologische
ideen gibt dies wird so begründet dass
wir das hier einschlägige vernunft
anliegen auf vollständigkeit einer reihe
nur die kategorien als basis taugen in
welchen die synthesis eine reihe
ausmacht und das sind 4 und daher
ergeben sich vier kosmologische ideen
das führt kann auch in einer tafel aus
aber da möchte ich hier nicht weiter
darauf eingehen
als die idee die der dritten antenne me
zugrunde liegt und die es im folgenden
besonders geht wird die idee der
vollständigkeit der entstehung einer
erscheinung genannt hier ist man daher
gleich mit einer schwierigkeit bei der
beantwortung was ideen sind konfrontiert
statt der idee der vollständigkeit der
entstehung einer erscheinung hätte man
als idee der kausalität oder als die der
kausalität entsprechende idee er die der
absoluten spontaneität der ursachen
erwartet also als kam gläser hat man da
vielleicht eine andere erwartungen der
stimme dies ist die idee der
transzendentalen freiheit freiheit ist
für kant zumindest im kern unbedingte
kausalität und das bedeutet ein vermögen
eine reihe von selbst anzufangen
diese idee steht im zentrum der dritten
antennen und sie wird auch von kant
explizit als transfer
zentrale idee bezeichnet als dritte
kosmologische idee kommt also erstens
die idee der vollständigkeit die
entstehung einer erscheinung in frage
einer der thesen die ich im folgenden
vertreten möchte lautet das kant in der
dritten antinori zwei kosmologische
ideen einführt auch wenn diese eng
miteinander verbunden sind
das ist sachlich nicht problematisch
denke ich dass er 2 1 führt aber es ist
erstens festzustellen dass kans eigener
aussagen zur anzahl der ideen dann in
diesem punkt missverständlich ist oder
korrigiert werden muss und zweitens
bedeutet es auch dass die fragen was
ideen sind und wie wir zu ihnen kommen
noch komplizierter beantwortet werden
muss werden müssen weil wir sehen werden
diese antworten sind für die beiden hier
betrachteten ideen also die der
vollständigkeit und die der freiheit
nicht gleich die idee der
vollständigkeit die entstehung einer
erscheinung entspricht offenbar jener
leitidee der vernunft die überhaupt für
die anti domain verantwortlich ist
nämlich das unbedingte von etwas
bedingten zu denken wobei das bedingte
hier teil einer reihe ist die durch die
kategorien hergestellt wird
die idee der absoluten spontaneität der
ursachen ist dagegen die antwort auf die
frage wie man diese vollständigkeit der
entstehung denken kann
also das sind die beiden ideen und das
ist habe ich erstmals angedeutet wie ich
den zusammenhang dieser beiden ideen
sehe das werde ich ihm folgen folgenden
aber noch mehr erläutern
diese zwei den betrag beachten kann man
vielleicht sagen dass die dritte antenne
nie so zu verstehen ist dass wir fragen
was es mit der idee der vollständigkeit
die entstehung der erscheinung
eigentlich auf sich hat
wir können auf diese frage zwei
vernünftige antworten geben
die positive antwort will diese idee
realisieren diese antwort impliziert
eine neue idee von kausalität nämlich
kausalität aus freiheit die negative
antwort weist nicht nur die idee
aus freiheit zurück sondern auch die
idee der absoluten vollständigkeit
hier könnte man auch sagen die positive
antwort sieht ein anliegen darin eine
absolute vollständigkeit anzunehmen und
dieses anlegen wird mit der negativen
antwort auch zurückgewiesen
mit positive und negative antwort meine
ich eben die these und antithese und die
werde ich im folgenden noch genauer
ausführen
nebenbei will man hier vielleicht fragen
was soll das heißen dass wir als
vernünftige wesen zwei behauptungen
aufstellen
obwohl diese doch offensichtlich im
widerspruch stehen hier auf werte ich
bei den fragen zur methode im dritten
teil meines vortrags zurückkommen klar
ist jedenfalls dass kann meint wir haben
gute gründe für beide behauptungen
schauen wir uns die antenne me genauer
an
die dritte antenne me behauptet nicht
dass der begriff der kausalität probleme
aufwirft die sich als alten emi antinori
darstellen lassen würde er das behaupten
würde dies zweifellos ein merkwürdiges
licht auf die analytik also auf den
bisherigen gang der kritik der reinen
vernunft werfen in der dieser begriff
aufgestellt und seine objektive realität
nachgewiesen wurde
denn auch hängt das problem direkt mit
dem verständnis von kausalität zusammen
und nicht etwa damit dass wir als
menschen verschiedener auffassen von und
als freie und determiniert haben die
strittige frage ist ob das prinzip der
qualität nur auf gesetze der natur
bezogen verstanden werden muss um die
natur zu erklären oder ob man eine
andere kausalität für natur erklärungen
braucht die antithese behauptet und
diese gegenüberstellung finden sie jetzt
eben auch immer auf dem handout und ich
beginne bei der darstellung der antenne
me also jetzt haben sie ja eben das
szenario dass sie these und gegenthese
haben oder these und antithese haben und
beide behaupten eben etwas über
kausalität beide widersprechen sich und
beide versuchen aber ihre these also die
these und die antithese entsprechend zu
begründen und ich beginne er mit der
anti these und sie finden die jeweiligen
zitate und ausführungen zur these und
antithese auf dem handy
wenn wir das dann leichter zu folgen und
übersichtlich schien die antithese
behauptet dass alles in der welt nach
gesetzen der natur geschieht
die erste und wichtigste begründung für
diese behauptung lautet dass freiheit
als ursache verstanden der
gesetzmäßigkeit widerspreche zitat natur
also und transzendentale freiheit
unterscheiden sich die gesetzmäßigkeit
und gesetzlosigkeit davon jene zur
schadlos erhaltung durchgängige und
gesetzmäßige einheit der erfahrung
verspricht diese begründung entspricht
der auch heute noch gängigen und
üblichen überlegungen dass wir für
unsere natur erklärungen einen
geschlossenen gesetzes zusammenhang
annehmen müssen und hier mit freiheit
als anfangen können einer reihe
das ist das hier einschlägige
freiheitsverständnis anfangen können
eine reihe unvereinbar sei
interessanterweise und kant in diesem
zusammenhang und zwar genau an der
stelle die ich in dem zitat ausgelassen
habe eine schwierigkeit für den verstand
ein den dieser mit der annahme von
gesetzmäßigkeit in kauf nehme zitat auch
das finden sie auf dem thesenpapier die
abstimmung der begebenheiten in der
reihe der ursachen immer höher hinauf zu
suchen
dies ist eine schwierigkeit interessant
ist dies deshalb weil diese so genannte
schwierigkeit in der argumentation für
die these und somit für die gegenthese
zur antithese eine rolle spielt in der
weiteren argumentation für die antithese
heißt es und hier besteht ein bezug zu
dieser schwierigkeit das einen ersten
anfang an zu nehmen nicht nötig sei da
es durchaus eine endlose abstammung
geben können
dies sei allerdings der möglichkeit und
nach für uns nicht begreiflich aber das
müsse auch nicht bei jeder annahme so
sein dass wir sie begreifen können auch
bei anderen annahmen sei dies nicht der
fall kann denkt hier zum beispiel an die
annahme von kräften bei denen die es
auch nicht der fall ist dass wir uns
deren möglichkeit begreiflich machen
können
trotzdem nehmen wir die an mit anderen
worten die schwierigkeit der annahme
einer im prinzip unendlichen suche in
der abstimmung weil man immer nach neuen
bitten nach neuen bedingten suchen muss
was dann wieder die ursache darstellen
kann ist für die antithese nicht
wirklich unüberwindbar weil man
zumindest nicht sagen muss dass es nicht
eine endlose abstammung geben könne
es könnte durchaus ökologisch gesehen
also das könnte durchaus eine endlose
abstimmung geben und in dem sinne ist
die ente unendliche suche in der
abstammung die man durch dieses prinzip
der gesetzmäßigkeit wenn das so
durchgängig und unbedingt gelten soll
dann annehmen muss nicht also aus der
perspektive der anti these nicht
problematisch man kann die antithese so
zusammenfassen obwohl für den verstand
eine gewisse schwierigkeit darin liegt
dass die suche nach bedingungen endlos
ist kann er keine andere ursache als
natur sache annehmen das heißt ursachen
die selbst wieder bedingt sind weil nur
wenn er ausschließlich selbst wieder
bedingte ursachen und keine andere
kausalität annimmt durchgänge
gesetzmäßig einheit als bedingung für
die erklärbar kite von naturphänomenen
besteht
und weil man eine unendliche abstammung
als gegeben annehmen darf so lässt sich
die durchgängige gesetzmäßigkeit der
bedingten natur ursachen auch ohne
widerspruch behaupten kommen wir damit
zur these die these der dritten antenne
lautet dass die qualität nach gesetzen
der natur nicht die einzige sei sondern
dass zur erklärung der erscheinung der
natur auch eine kausalität aus freiheit
notwendig anzunehmen sei wichtig ist wie
schon betont habe dass wir zur folge der
these die annahme einer anderen qualität
für natur erklärungen brauchen und nicht
etwa weil sie unserem selbstverständnis
entspricht oder ähnliches wir brauchen
diese annahme einer anderen qualität so
die überlegung weil wir ohne sie keine
vollständigkeit der reihe an dem
können dies sollen wir aber gerade tun
können um natur erklärungen liefern zu
können
wieso das ist besteht so fährt kann
frost zitat eben darin dass das finden
sie jetzt auch wieder auf dem handy
so fährt kann ford eben darin das gesetz
der natur das ohne hinreichend apriori
bestimmte ursachen nichts geschehe
also widerspricht der satz als wenn alle
kausalität nur nach naturgesetzen
möglich sei sich selbst in seiner
unbeschränkten allgemeinheit und diese
kann also nicht die einzige angenommen
als die einzige angenommen werden kann
fasst es so zusammen dass ohne
transzendentale freiheit selbst im laufe
der natur
die reihenfolge der erscheinungen auf
der seite der ursachen niemals
vollständig ist
die man sieht spielt in dieser
argumentation der these die idee der
absoluten vollständigkeit die
entscheidende positive rolle während sie
in der anti these abgelehnt wird und die
idee der freiheit wird eingeführt um
diese vollständigkeit zu gewähren ist
was bedeutet die idee der absoluten
vollständigkeit der entstehung einer
erscheinung die kategorie der kausalität
ist ein prinzip der ursache wirkungs
relation mit dem man die entstehung
einer erscheinen erklären kann und nach
kann ja auch erklären muss will man
erscheinungen objektiv erkennen
auf dieses prinzip der kausalität ist
die idee der vollständigkeit der
erscheinung der entstehung der
erscheinung bezogen
es ist ihr allerdings sozusagen der satz
des zureichenden grundes an die stelle
des kausal prinzips getreten und der
leibniz bezug ist offensichtlich aber
wie kommt es dazu man kann vielleicht
sagen die idee resultiert daraus dass
wir in zwei hinsichten eine neue
perspektive auf dieses prinzip der
kausalität einnehmen erstens das
bedingte wird als etwas verstanden dass
unabhängig von seiner erfahrung durch
uns als bedingtes gegeben ist und es
wird zweiter
angenommen das ist vollständig gegeben
sein kommen können muss weil nur dann
eine vollständige erklärung möglich sei
die beiden behauptungen 1 und 2
gehören in der argumentation eng
zusammen die erste behauptung läuft
darauf hinaus dass wir uns auf dinge an
sich beziehen
sie kann auch ohne die zweite vertreten
werden und dies geschieht in der anti
these schwieriger ist die zweite
behauptung mit ihr scheint man wiederum
verschiedenes zu behaupten erstens
scheint eine behauptung zu sein dass die
reihe der bedingung des bedingten
vollständig gegeben sein muss dass die
reihe vollständig gegeben sein muss soll
gelten weil angenommen wird dass sich
erklärungen auf dinge an sich beziehen
wenn es dinge an sich sind so muss man
die gesamtheit alles bedingten denken
vielleicht muss man es nicht mal zu
fassen können weil es gegeben war
dies ist vielleicht noch unstrittig und
der vertreter der anti these könnte dem
zustimmen auch wenn er wie wir gesehen
haben ja annimmt dass der reihe endlos
sein könnte zweitens scheint man aber zu
behaupten dass eine vollständige
erklärung erforderlich sei dies wiederum
impliziert dass man das gegebene
bedingte zumindest im prinzip auch
erfassen kann und dies schließt dann
eine gegebene endlose reihe aus die bei
der anti these angenommen wird mit
anderen worten eine erklärung setzt
voraus nach meinung der these dass die
bedingungen hinreichend für das bedingte
sind man muss dann aber so die
überlegung der these auf alle
bedingungen im prinzip bezug nehmen
können und so eine vollständige
erklärung geben können
man kann aber so die überlegung weiter
nichts bedingtes als diejenige ursache
annehmen die die reihe abschließt denn
bedingtes hätte wieder eine ursache
daher muss man einen ersten anfang
denken an dieser stelle mag mancher
vielleicht irritiert fragen ist diese
antinori nicht schon durch die analytik
gelöst weil durch sie doch schon klar
ist dass die antithese recht hat wenn
sie die gültigkeit der natur kausalität
behauptet das ist aber nicht der fall
die analytik also der bisherige teil der
kritik der reinen vernunft kann die
antithese so wenig stützen wie die these
der fehler der anti these liegt darin
dass sie die gültigkeit des natur
prinzips schlechthin behauptet und die
möglichkeit jede anderen kausalität
abstreitet sie tut dies weil sie an
dass die erklärungen dinge an sich
betreffen wenn die erklärungen dinge an
sich betreffen dann stehen die dinge in
diesem gesetzmäßigen zusammenhang und
wenn man daran festhalten will ist keine
andere kausalität möglich der fehler des
vertreters der anti these liegt also
darin die natur gesetzlichkeit nicht als
prinzip der sind es bloß erscheinungen
zu nehmen
treffend sagt in diesem sinne der
vertreter der these dass der satz dass
alle kausalität nur nach naturgesetze
möglich sei sich selbst in seiner und
das jetzt zu betonen unbeschränkten
allgemeinheit widerspreche da hat also
der vertreter der these gegen die
antithese recht kann selbst hat diese
unbeschränkte allgemeinheit nie
behauptet sondern nur die notwendige
allgemeinheit für bloss für bloße
erscheinungen
dies ist wichtig zu bemerken denn dann
ist auch klar
sowohl der vertreter der these als auch
der vertreter der anti these machen den
fehler dass sie am namen annehmen unsere
erklärung betreffen dinge an sich ist
dieser fehler gemacht hat man die
alternative von these und antithese
beide haben einen guten grund die these
denen dass man eine hinreichende
erklärung will die antithese denen das
naturgesetz lichkeit durchgehend sein
muss daher wird man entweder wie in der
these die natur qualität ohne
einschränkung behaupten dann kann man
nicht behaupten dass man eine
vollständige oder hinreichende erklärung
für etwas geben kann
denn die annahme der mögliche möglichen
hinreichenden erklärung widerspricht der
these der endlosen abstimmung oder man
nimmt wie die these zwei arten von
kausalität an
damit hat man allerdings eine
schwierigkeit mit jeder art von natur
erklärung weil man zwei arten von
kausalität für dieselben dinge annehmen
muss der meinung ist jedenfalls kann
wohlgemerkt in these und antithese in
ihren defiziten nicht gleich und kann
behauptet dies auch nicht für die
antithese die die empirischen vertreten
haben sollen spricht dass sie mit natur
erklärung doch letztlich besser
zurechtkommt die these obwohl auch in
diesem kontext entwickelt muss in der
erklärung
von natur sachen mit zwei naturbegriff
2q seoul begriffen letztlich scheitern
für die these spricht dass sie unseren
praktischen bedürfnissen besser rechnung
tragen kann darauf also auf diese
asymmetrie werde ich in meinem letzten
teil noch zurückkommen
hier ist aber zunächst folgendes
festzuhalten es gilt das these und
antithese einander widersprechende sätze
mit jeweils guter begründung sind die
auf dem selben fehler beruhen
der fehler besteht in der annahme der
bezogenheit von uns auf dinge an sich
beide machen diesen fehler der sie ja
dann auch in schwierigkeiten bringt
obwohl wohlgemerkt oder vertreter der
these ein verfechter von vernunft ideen
ist für kans auffassung der rolle der
ideen ist das entscheidend etwas lax
könnte man sagen die ideen sind nicht
das problem sondern die annahme des
bezugs auf dinge an sich unter dieser
voraussetzung ist die bildung der ideen
nicht nur eine quasi natürliche also
rationale folge
sie ist sogar gleichwertig mit der
zurückweisung der ideen
allerdings kann man diese zurückweisung
von ideen für die antithese auch wieder
infrage stellen denn immerhin betrachtet
der vertreter der anti these dass kausal
prinzip als schlechthin gültig
ohne eine ohne jede einschränkung
gültiges prinzip kann man auch wieder
als eine idee ansehen
dies wäre aber dann die einzige idee die
er sich also der vertreter hier und die
er sich wohl unbewusst zu eigen macht
die idee der vollständigkeit der
entstehung der erscheinung ist demnach
die leitende idee der vernunft bei der
these
sie lässt sich aus zu zensieren in den
aspekt der vollständig vollständigen
gegeben hat der reihe und den einer
vollständigen erklärung letztere dient
als begründung dafür warum wir für die
vollständige reihe wiederum ein grund
denken müssen
denn kurz gesagt lautet die überlegung
wir suchen eine hinreichende erklärung
und diese kann nur gegeben werden wenn
man einen unbegründeten grund oder in
anfang der reihe nimmt wenn man ernst
nimmt was ich in diesem kontext
ausgeführt habe so stellt man fragen der
vernunft also nicht etwa des verstandes
sondern fragen der vernunft in den
zusammenhang der möglichkeit von natur
erklärung in der formulierung der
dritten anti nomi macht kann dies meines
erachtens eindeutig denn these und
antithese beziehen sich auf die
möglichkeit von natur erklärung
ansonsten klingt es aber bisweilen auch
so als würde kam der vernunft einfach
natürlicherweise das bedürfnis oder das
interesse unterstellen das unbedingte
oder die qualität von etwas zu denken
dies klingt etwa an wenn kann sagt da
aber auf eine solche weise also durch
den verstand und sein prinzip bei dem
alles wiederum als entstanden angenommen
wird keine absolute totalität der
bedingungen im casal verhältnis
herauszubekommen ist so schafft sich die
vernunft die idee von einer spontanität
also so als wären wir einfach
unbefriedigt wenn wir uns immer nur mit
bedingte beschäftigten und als hätten
wir ein bedürfnis was dann der vernunft
zugeschrieben wird nach etwas
unbedingten zu gucken so klingt das an
vielen stellen aber in dem kontext der
dritten antinori ist das auf jeden fall
nicht so sondern da wird die idee des
der spontanität oder die idee des
unbedingten eingeführt um die natur
erklären meisten zu können folgt man
einer deutung der dritten anti nomi so
müsste man genauer sagen die positive
annahme von ideen ist eine von zwei
möglichen thesen über die natur wenn man
den fehler macht anzunehmen dass wir uns
mit unseren prinzipien auf dinge an sich
beziehen können und wenn man also natur
erklärungen in diesem sinn versteht und
das zu sagen muss man noch kein
besonderes bedürfnis nach dem
unbedingten der vernunft annehmen
erst bei der frage ob wir uns für die
these oder für die antithese entscheiden
würden wenn wir uns zwischen ihnen
entscheiden müssten würde das bedürfnis
der vernunft eine runde spielen kommt er
zur antwort auf die frage wie ideen
entstehen lässt sich mit blick auf die
idee der vollständigkeit der entstehung
angeben was kann meint wenn er für die
transzendentale
ideen behauptet wie hier angeführt habe
sie bezögen sich auf kategorien aber so
dass sie deren beschränkungen weglassen
die idee der vollständigkeit bezieht
sich auf die kategorie der kausalität
sie betrifft fragen zur vollständigen
erklärung bei kausale zusammenhängen wie
ich gerade ausgeführt habe vor allem
aber ist sie und auch der umgang mit ihr
auf seiten der these und antithese eine
folge der missdeutung der kategorie der
kausalität die kategorie ist eine regel
der synthesis vom bloßen erscheinungen
nur wenn man dies nicht beachtet macht
es sinn auf die vollständigkeit der
entstehung zu drängen
der bezug zur kategorie der kausalität
besteht in diesem fall also in einer
zitat missdeutung unserer erfahrungs
begriffe wie kant an einer stelle sagt
diese missdeutung kann man durchaus auch
so beschreiben dass beschränkungen der
kategorie weggelassen werden weil die
einschränkung in der gültigkeit auf
erscheinungen eine beschränkung
darstellt die idee der vollständigkeit
die entstehung ist eine vernunft idee
und um sie geht der streit
obwohl sich nur eine der seiten diese
idee zu eigen macht missdeuten doch
beide den erfahrungs begriff den
erfahrungs begriff das heißt beide
beziehen sich zwar klar auf die idee der
vollständigkeit aber nicht bei der
affirmativ denn die antithese
diese idee ab sie setzt das großarl
prinzip als schlechthin gültig bei der
these und deren bejagung der idee tritt
eine weitere transzendentale ideen den
vordergrund durch die das ziel der
vollständigkeit erreicht werden können
soll die idee der freiheit auch diese
idee ist auf kausalität bezogen
mit ihr wird bekannt nämlich eine andere
art der qualität als die der natur
gesetzmäßigkeit angenommen
da erscheint die rede von der
erweiterten kategorie die kanten blick
auf die ideenwelt auch hier angebracht
naheliegender weise könnte man sagen
dass mit der freiheit ein grund folge
verhältnis auf etwas nicht zeitliches
bezogen wird und dass die kategorie in
diesem sinn erweitert wird
man könnte hier dann sogar von einer
idee der kausalität sprechen da es um
eine kausalität geht die nicht auf rein
zeitliches beschränkt sein soll
dies ist auch eine erklärung für die
rede davon dass wir uns bei ideen auf
kategorien beziehen aber ihre
beschränkungen weglassen
das ist eine andere erklärung als die
die ich für die vollständigkeit gegeben
habe
denn gemeint wäre hier die beschränkung
der gültigkeit auf raum und zeit die für
diese kausalität nicht angenommen werden
außer macht der entstehung kann man auch
fragen ob die ideen eigentlich ein
inhalt oder eine bedeutung haben können
ich habe schon am anfang gesagt es
bekannt die ideen nicht bedeutungslos
sind die idee der freiheit scheint ein
inhalt zu haben aber woher entlehnt sie
das verständnis von der thematisierten
kategorie obwohl sie selbst gerade kein
zeitliches verhältnis etablieren will
die weise wie diese idee gebildet wird
nämlich ausdrücklich als idee von etwas
unbedingten spricht dafür
man könnte vielleicht sagen dass wir
diese idee in einer negation der
thematisierten kategorie bekommen also
die schema ti sierte kategorie der
kausalität wäre die dass ich eine folge
von ereignissen objektiv nur bestimmen
kann indem ich angeben welches welches
ereignis nicht vor oder nach einem
anderen macht also eine objektive
zeitfolge in dem ich an gebe wie die
einflüsse aufeinander geschehen und das
ist meine schema visierte kategorie das
ist das verständnis von kausalität was
ich da habe dieses verhältnis das eben
nicht 1 habe und dass andere darauf
folgen muss und dass auch ein
umgekehrtes verhältnis geben kann
dieses diese bedeutung die übernehme ich
obwohl
ich dass in dem im fall der der
kategorie gerade nur mit blick auf zeit
verhältnisse gemacht habe ich lasse
quasi belastet quasi mein verständnis
der kausalität von dem wie ich es bei
der kategorie kenne und meine dasselbe
ließe sich auch auf verhältnisse
anwenden die selbst nicht raum zeitlich
wäre die idee von einem ersten anfang
scheint die vernunft zu erschaffen aber
sie tut dies zumindest in der dritten
antinori im rahmen ihrer auffassung von
kausalität bei natur erklärung ideen
wären demnach so etwas wie begriffe die
nicht mehr als werkzeuge zur erkenntnis
verwendet werden können weil sie aus dem
relevanten zusammenhang des
verständnisses der natur als erscheinung
herausgelöst worden sind die aber
dennoch nicht ohne bedeutung sind weil
sie ihre bedeutung von den begriffen
noch hinlegen können die der verstand
gebraucht zur frage nach dem inhalt kann
man nach dem was hier ausgeführt wurde
mit blick auf die idee der
vollständigkeit noch folgendes ergänzen
weil sie etwas mit der frage zu tun hat
wie man erklärungen liefern kann kann
man sie mit den kategorien als regel
oder verfahrensweise parallelisieren und
in diesem sinn einer spezifischen regeln
der synthesis könnten sie inhalt haben
allerdings sind die ideen als regeln der
sind es ist gerade nicht gültig anders
als die kategorien und funktionieren
nicht sie haben also keinen inhalt wenn
man damit meint dass sie funktionieren
der regel sind es sind die idee der
vollständigkeit der entstehung der
erscheinung ist aber auch nicht wie etwa
die idee gottes eine idee von einem
eigenen gegenstand sie könnte zwar auf
die annahme eines gegenstands führen
dies muss aber nicht so sein in beiden
fällen bei der idee der vollständigkeit
der entstehung der erscheinung und bei
der idee der freiheit kann man also
sagen die vernunft hat ideen diese sind
nicht bloß erscheinen und sie sind
unterschieden von den kategorien aber
die ideen werden
indem man von den kategorien ausgeht und
diese missdeutet damit kam ich zu meinem
dritten teil der bevölkerung für die
fragen zur methode die überlegungen zu
ideen haben weitreichende folgen für die
fragen zu kannst methode und mit diesem
thema beschäftige ich mich in diesem
dritten teil
zunächst ist wichtig zu sehen dass wir
es bekannt bei der theorie der ideen
nicht primär mit einer kritik an anderen
philosophen oder teilen der philosophie
zu tun haben
bei den anti nahm ihn und er sucht kant
wie es zu dem kommt und woher sie ihren
inhalt haben
er diagnostiziert weiterhin den fehler
der dazu geführt hat ideen eine
erkenntnis funktion zuzusprechen
die philosophen vorkampf namen nicht
fälschlicherweise ideen am wohl ihnen
gar nichts entspricht das würde ja jetzt
wieder eben einer moderneren auffassung
der kritik an sowas wie ideen
entsprechen
der fehler der philosophen lag darin
dass sie die ideen verwendet haben um
mit einer situation zurechtzukommen in
die sie falsche anderen geführt haben
nehmen nicht die falsche annahme dass
wir uns auf dinge an sich beziehen
können man kann hier von einer
selbstkritik der vernunft reden
das wirft die frage auf die man auch
leicht gegen kann wenden kann
wie soll denn die hier intendierte
selbsterkenntnis möglich sein
die ausführung zum antinori in kapitel
sollen gezeigt haben dass
selbsterkenntnis hier meint das
untersucht wird was man macht wenn man
ideen bildet ist also ein sagen wir mal
sehr dramatischer begriff von
selbsterkenntnis der hier meines
erachtens eine rolle spielt wenn wir
überlegen wie wir ideen generieren
werden wir beispielsweise darauf
aufmerksam dass sie ihre bedeutung
dadurch haben dass wir sie in bezug auf
die kategorien gebildet haben
philosophieren ist hier zu verstehen als
eine reflektion auf die eigenen
fähigkeiten und denkt handlungen bei der
wir eben funktion und
von begriffen einsehen können die
scheint mir keine uninteressante aber
auch keine problematische annahme über
eine der aufgaben der philosophie zu
sein
es ist damit keine erkenntnis im engeren
sinne gemeint obwohl es auch nicht nur
um eine kritik an anderen position geht
gemeint ist eine art philosophisch
klären der analyse die uns hilft
ansprüche der erkenntnis gegebenenfalls
zu korrigieren und die uns vor fehlern
bewahrt
eine andere frage was ist wahr jetzt
quasi zu der grundthese die man
philosophieren bekannt allgemein
verstehen können eine andere frage zur
methode lässt sich hier anschließen kann
behauptet dass die dialektik die
ergebnisse der analytik nicht
voraussetzt sondern diese bestätige mit
der analyse der angenehm ihnen soll
sogar ein indirekter beweis für kahns
these des transzendentalen idealismus
geliefert werden
auch hier kann man kann kritisch fragen
wie kann hier wo eigentlich erkenntnis
gerade nicht möglich sein soll ein
indirekter beweis geführt werden
nach meinen ausführungen kann man das so
verstehen die schwierigkeiten in die wir
mit den anti domain kommen ergeben sich
durch die missdeutung der erfahrungs
begriffe also dann wenn wir meinen die
anhand der kategorien geleisteten
synthesen müssten den dingen an sich
entsprechen der transzendentalen
idealismus vermeidet diese schwierigkeit
und darin besteht das argument für den
transzendentalen idealismus von den
ergebnissen der analytik ist dieses
ergebnis tatsächlich nur insofern
abhängig als die dritte angeli sich auf
die kategorie der kausalität bezieht sie
setzt aber nicht deren beschränkte
geltung voraus sondern nimmt im
gegenteil an dass dieses prinzip sich
auf dinge an sich beziehen müsse also
ich bin daher auch nicht der meinung
dass bei dieser antenne me das problem
vorliegt was manche
gesehen haben nämlich dass kant den
transzendentalen idealismus also sein
transzendentalen idealismus seine
position in der philosophie voraussetze
und dass er ihnen daher gar nicht
beweisen könne ja in dem sinne in dem
ich jetzt erläutert habe kann man meines
erachtens daher durchaus von einem
indirekten beweis sprechen
sie lässt sich aber nach harten
natürlich kann man bestreiten dass die
annahme des bezugs auf dinge an sich und
für die genannte alternative von these
und antithese stellt weiterhin kann
bestreiten dass diese alternative
wirklich gleichberechtigt sind diese
alternativen wirklich gleichberechtigt
sind was macht ihre gleichwertigkeit
oder gleichberechtigung eigentlich aus
die haben eine ausführung bereits
andeutungen auf eine entscheidende
einschränkung in der gleichwertigkeit
enthalten
und das wie folgt wenn man als priorität
die möglichkeit von natur erklärung
setzt so kann die antithese den
wettstreit für sich gewinnen
die annahme der these die am an der
these verhindern die annahme einer
möglichen vollständigen erklärung aber
sie lassen anders entschuldigung die
annahme der abt antithese verhindern die
annahme einer möglichen vollständigen
erklärung aber sie lassen
anders als die these das prinzip der
natur sachen intakt der nachteil liegt
für die antithese daran dass man dem
anspruch auf vollständigkeit nicht
gerecht werden kann so wie auch das von
kanten quasi sekundär ein dass man den
praktischen interesse also etwa dem
anspruch auf erklärbar kite frei
handlungen nicht gerecht werden kann
aber hier in muss man natürlich keinen
schlagenden einwand sehen
es gibt heute viele die dies nicht tun
wie japans augen auch schon die ersten
dies nicht getan haben dies bedenken
sollte man nicht wie kant von einem
beweis für den transzendentalen
idealismus reden und auch nicht von so
etwas wie einem indiz für dessen
wahrheit
man kann aber sagen dass schwächere
formulieren formulierung wählen
das ist ein vorteil des trans mentalen
idealismus ist dass er mehr motive und
anliegen als jeweils these und antithese
aufnehmen beziehungsweise befriedigen
kann
hier möchte ich aber noch einen anderen
punkt hervorheben die zwei behauptungen
werden beide als gut begründet
vorgestellt und als gleichwertig
betrachtet
die soll ja die antinori ausmachen dies
scheint dann aber so gemeint dass für
beide annahmen dieselbe art von
gleichgewicht
dies scheint dann aber nicht so gemeint
dass wir beide annahmen dieselbe art man
gleich gewichtigen gründen sprechen wie
ich ausgeführt habe ist ja die these für
die möglichkeit der natur erklärung
besser unter cantz bedingungen und unter
ihren eigenen bedingungen für die these
sprechen so dann auch kant letztlich
mehr praktische interessen wenn man sich
zwischen denen entscheiden müsste hier
wird man vielleicht einwenden dass die
gleichwertigkeit von these und antithese
ihn etwas ganz anderem liegen soll
diese könnte vielmehr dadurch zustande
kommen dass beide die these entwickeln
die auf einer falschen fahrer die auf
falschen voraussetzungen beruhen und die
sich weder überprüfen noch trans
emmental beweisen müssen es wäre dann
trotz verschiedener erklärungs kraft
eine epidemische und nicht eine
pragmatische gleichwertigkeit gemeint
aber das geht natürlich nur aber dies
geht natürlich tatsächlich nur wenn man
die wahrheit des transzendentalen
idealismus voraussetzt von kampf
standpunkt aus betrachtet sind sie dann
gleichwertig weil man eben sagen würde
ihre gleichwertigkeit liegt darin dass
sie beide ihre these und antithese vor
einer falschen annahme entwickeln aber
das tun sie natürlich nur wenn man also
in den augen desjenigen der
transzendentale idealistischer vom
standpunkt kam es aus betrachtet wären
sie dann in diesem sinne gleichwertig
aber wenn these und antithese mit ihren
eigenen annahmen des bezugs auf dinge an
sich letztlich epidemisch nicht
gleichwertig sind kann man dann
überhaupt noch von einer anti nomi
sprechen
ich denke an dieser stelle ist es wird
verkannt
eine möglichkeit dass man diese idee der
vollständigen erklärung noch klarer mit
in verbindung mit natur erklärung
hervorhebt und dann tatsächlich eine
epidemische gleichwertigkeit von these
und antithese klarer herstellt als ich
das jetzt insgesamt in
texter gibt aber das wäre eine größere
diskussion die sich dann anschließen
würde
die antinori besteht also nur von cannes
standpunkt aus nicht aus der perspektive
von these und antithese wenn man kann es
eigener darstellung mit diesem
verschiedenen gewichtungen der gründe
folgt zwischen diesen muss ja auch gar
nicht entschieden werden weil sie auf
einer falschen voraussetzung beruhen
was macht dann an dieser stelle
eigentlich der philosoph dass der streit
zwischen these und antithese nicht
entschieden wird zeigt sich auch in der
geschichte der philosophie
das heißt natürlich nicht dass er nicht
entscheid bei ist er ist vielleicht
einfach nur bisher nicht entschieden
worden
aber der philosoph probiert angesichts
dessen aus was die scheinbare und
lesbarkeit des streits verursachen haben
könnte er experimentiert mit annahmen
und szenarien um dies zu klären wenn er
eine lösung findet oder einen vorschlag
dazu hat muss er diese natürlich auch
noch anders prüfen
zunächst ist philosophie aber auch wie
kann selbst in der zweiten vorrede in
anderem zusammenhang gesagt hat
experimentieren
dafür geben die falsche verwendung von
ideen ebenso wie kann es auflösung der
antenne me schöne beispiele
ich danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit